this piece behind me is the Raygun
gothic rocket ship and it is our
interpretation of 1930s 1940s science
fiction of what people imagined space
travel might be in the future it's all
fabricated by hand by our volunteer crew
this is the main ladder it's about 18
feet tall it's going to bring us into
the engine room and bio containment labs
so why don't you come on aboard and
let's take a look at the ship all right
guys welcome aboard this is the engine
room and life sciences lab or bio
containment lab as I like to think about
it first thing that we should look at is
the plasma drive this is the liter
engine in the floor beneath your feet
now we're doing a daytime installation
and so we haven't fully done out all the
trim and the effect but this is a
two-tier kinetic effect that runs on
high-voltage we use about 15,000 volts
to create a plasma inside each of the
cylinders in the specimen behind me his
name is Ivan he's from Thalia six one of
the planets that we visited in our last
voyage he seems to be mostly harmless
he's actually a pretty intelligent
creature sleeps a lot particularly likes
kids this guy right here in the bio
station student is actually what I like
to call a prosthetic alien and
ham as a test platform for the expo
biologists to study to learn how to
dissect alien creatures and so as you
can see we can subject him to various
neural stem solar radiation and other
kinds of stimuli to just see what he
might do see how the exobiologist might
handle it or try to diagnose it his
issues
to keep Italian things for the chief
engineer lop rates down here we have the
ship systems panel which can ultimately
provide status on things like Power
Cells bio containment comms and life
support as well as you know more
important things like oxygen the larger
and beer supply so we to have a rocket
launcher or a torpedo launcher or a
probe launcher depending on
circumstances so this is the Hollis 9000
remote sensor system capable of being
emitted with both sensor packages as
well as self defense packages
so we're up here on the flight deck at
this point this is the pilots position
from here I have primary flight controls
system scanning devices and I have the
ability to rotate and access all of the
various ship systems that I might need
to get to from here we're hoping to
bring it to the waterfront in San
Francisco and in that configuration
it'll be a static display and to
highlight the interior elements and the
interactivity we're crafting a rocket
stop think bus stop for rocket ships